peltz qui marquent l'actualité ce matin
aux membres de la première nation micmac
qui a perdu la vie hier soir lors d'une
intervention policière à miramichi au
nouveau-brunswick
c'est le bureau des enquêtes
indépendantes du québec qui est chargée
de l'enquêté
événement qui survient une semaine
seulement après la mort de chanter deux
mois une jeune femme autochtone a battu
également par un policier au nouveau
brunswick idée marche en sa mémoire se
déroule en après midi aujourd'hui en
simultanée dans plusieurs villes j'en
parle ce matin avec bernard richard
conseiller en protection de l'enfance
auprès de 6 première nation micmac du
nouveau brunswick ancien protecteur du
citoyen nouveau brunswick est également
sur champ bonjour bonjour madame ma cour
on devait ce matin et ce par les
démarches à la mémoire de chantelle mois
voilà que s'ajoute sept autres
autochtones qui a été tué par la police
hier soir oui c'est sûr je connais pas
les circonstances j'ai vu ce qui circule
dans les médias mais c'est sûr que ça
vient alimenter un feu qui qui lâche
déjà depuis quelques jours ici à quel
point ça vous préoccupe ce qui se passe
actuellement on a parlé beaucoup des
relations entre la police et les
personnes d'origine autochtone ya le
premier ministre justin trudeau qui a
déclaré cette semaine qu'il fallait
vraiment une enquête publique que les
événements de la semaine entre autres
l'arrestation musclée d'un chef
autochtone en alberta démontré un grand
besoin de faire la lumière là dessus
le premier mettra certainement de
pouvoir de t'engager une enquête
publique sur tous ces événements qui
sont très troublant pour nous tous et
mais certainement une des choses qui
pourraient se faire bien avant une
enquête publique on cite des enquêtes ça
peut prendre des années et souvent les
résultats sont plus ou moins mitigés
mais on pourrait déjà d'abord par
exemple impliqué des autochtones des
experts d'autochtones dans les enquêtes
qui ont lieu maintenant
grande méfiance à l'égard des policiers
y compris des organismes plus
indépendants comme comme le bureau des
enquêtes indépendantes du québec donc
peu importe ce que ce que les enquêteurs
vont trouver ça ça risque de ne pas
satisfaire les communautés autochtones
à moins qu'ils aient eu l'occasion d'y
participer directement
je pense que c'est pas le cas pour les
pour les deux enquêtes en cours
maintenant nouveau brunswick
on pourrait mieux former les agents
aussi on pourrait on pourrait acheter
des caméras coop horaire ça se règle pas
tous les problèmes ont entendu plusieurs
experts de la tunisie durant la dernière
semaine mais mais pour les policiers qui
suivent les normes qui respectent les
normes qui qui qui font les choses
correctement
ils et elles n'ont rien à craindre de
camille roques pour un enfant ça
pourrait se pourrait les aider dans leur
travail
donc il ya bien des choses qui peuvent
se faire mais plus fondamentalement à
mon sens il faut absolument creuser
l'écart qui de disparités qui existent
dans les communautés autochtones du
canada d'un bout à l'autre du canada la
pauvreté et les pénurie de logements les
problèmes de dépendances la litanie ne
finit plus c'est il ya des choses qui
paraissent pas immédiatement bien avant
et on ne les connaissez très bien ces
conditions là vous avez été vous même
ministre des affaires autochtones ou
nouveau brunswick jeudi l'entrée de jeu
assez protecteur du citoyen au nouveau
brunswick est également conseillé en
protection de l'enfance auprès de six
premières nations au mic mac
cet homme justement la qualité de ce
fait hier soir par la police
il est
attitude une première nation micmac au
nouveau brunswick est ce que vous avez
eu des communications avec des gens de
la communauté on vous sent fort ébranlé
sur champs ce matin oui c'est ça
s'ajoute une situation une tension qui
déjà très forte
le chef de la communauté voisine de
celle où habite la victime habitait la
victime m'a envoyé un texto hier soir on
devait participer à une démarche
aujourd'hui hélas annulé pour rester
près des siens après de la communauté
voisine de mettre rennes à gaillac qui
est la communauté de la victime s'était
d'ailleurs une de nos communautés donc
c'est certain que comme j'ai dit je ne
connais pas les circonstances ont ils se
pourraient prendre comme un embout tas
avant quand on est toutes les
informations mais si c'est clair que peu
importe des circonstances s'ajoute une
tension dont on n'avait pas de besoins
suite au décès de madame ur la semaine
dernière puis ça ça ça ne contribue en
rien à la confiance déjà fragile qui
existe entre les communautés les
résidents de ces communautés
les communautés autochtones du
nouveau-brunswick et les forces
policières et on va suivre le
déroulement justement de ces marche à la
mémoire de chanter moi un peu plus tard
cet après midi avec nos reporters
déployés un peu partout sur le terrain
bernard merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin 2 rien merci de vous
intéresser à ce sujet très important
c'est naturel merci beaucoup